a different person all of these sorts of
things right the things everybody
promises like if you do this you're
going to become a new person you're
going to see life differently but man my
family my friends everybody can testify
that I am a completely different person
everything was so clear so simple
everything made sense I didn't realize
it at the time but when I was younger I
felt like I was always reaching for
something like I was never really like
satisfied like I was looking for the
next best thing running jiujitsu I want
to a neuroscientist I want this is the
answer this is what I'm here to do and
when I came to Islam
alhamdulillah life has just become super
simple a different person all of these
sorts of things right the things
everybody promises like if you do this
you're going to become a new person
you're going to see life differently but
man my family my friends everybody can
testify that I am a completely different
person every